eux ce sont les hippies les cheveux lui
les déguiser les indiens les néo ruraux
comme les appellent les services
officiels les néoruraux un terme apparu
au milieu des années 70 et qui englobe
toute cette frange de la population qui
en a marre de la ville vais t'en
ordinateur planning grandement la ville
la ville que ce couple a fui justement
pour ouvrir un restaurant dans les
cévennes
est-ce que vous avez laissé à paris rien
aucun regret
comme cet ancien ouvrier qui s'est mis à
l'élevage avec succès dans un hameau
abandonné de l'ardèche travailler en
usine c'est pas forcément agréable à
travailler à la chaîne c'est pas mal non
plus et si on s'y retrouve on est bien
c'est on est paysan dans l'âme je crois
je pense aussi la littérature les a
souvent représenté en train de faire du
fromage de chèvre là-haut accrochée sur
la colline mais ils seront aussi vanier
charpentier hôtelier qui n'est une
arrivée qui n'est pas toujours bien vu
ce maire d'un village ardéchois par
exemple ne les aime pas mais pas du tout
ben alors reproche d'être désert weisser
surtout et ensuite d'avoir des notions
sur la propreté qui sentent un peu comme
moi je pourrais dire qu'ils sont un peu
en marge même des minimums tollé auprès
des banques
aussi c'est compliqué notamment pour cet
ingénieur d'études qui se lancer dans
l'élevage de moutons
le changement est très mal admis en
france cela ne m'est pas que quelqu'un
change de métier on vous fait des tas
d'obstacles au presse c'est vraiment
certains néo ruraux sont retournés vivre
en ville d'autres ont réussi leur
ancrage
financièrement en tout cas car
socialement c'est plus compliqué donc on
n'a déjà plus des néoruraux et pourtant
on reste des hippies et des ip ou on
l'est autant pour les gens qu'on a
quitté enfin le milieu sociologiques ont
acquitté que pour les gens qu'on a
trouvé ici il ya les anciens d'un côté
les nouveaux de l'autre est-ce que c'est
embêtant
vous vous pensé rester dans la région
moi je moi je suis installé je suis
propriétaire de ma maison maintenant
pour moi c'est j'arrive à dire qu'au
bout de dix ans mes racines sont ici